In the previous video, we were talking
about different types of scaling and the
last thing that we discussed was
horizontal scaling and this is the
continuation of that video. So if you
are watching this video the first time,
so please watch the first part of the
video to have better context. We'll just
jump ahead and continue from where we
left off. I divided this video into two
parts because of some frame corruption
issue in my recording software. Dividing
videos into part one, part two is not my
intention, but I had to do it for this
one. Anyway, continuing from where we
left, a very important property when we
are talking about horizontal scaling is
statelessness. The key enabler or the
key property that makes horizontal
scaling possible is this property which
is statelessness. And what do we mean by
statelessness? If we have our backend
applications and we have multiple
instances of our backend application
that is what we mean by horizontal
scaling if you remember which is adding
different machines of the same capacity
instead of increasing the capacity of a
single machine. That's what we mean by
horizontal scaling. So for horizontal
scaling we add multiple instances of our
back end which means multiple servers
which is which are running the same
code. And when we finally deploy our
application which is multiple instances
of our application over the internet and
the internet traffic comes our users
start making request to our back end or
they use our front end which in turn
makes request to our back end. All these
requests from our client is distributed
among all these instances. But before
that we are discussing about
statelessness. Now the only reason
horizontal scaling is possible because
of this property which is called
statelessness which means this is
possible because one server one instance
one machine in this chain does not
contain any kind of data which is
exclusive to this server. That is what
we mean by being stateful. When we say
stateful we mean that our server holds
some kind of information, some kind of
data which is exclusive to that server.
It remembers some kind of information
about the client, about the user and it
stores that information in the server.
And if something like that happens, if
let's say this is instance A, B, C and
D. If the instance D holds some amount
of data which the instance C or the
instance A does not have access to and
it is exclusive to this instance only
then our horizontal scaling will not
work as expected and we will see weird
errors pop up in our entire stack. So
this is what we meant in the initial
part of the discussion when we said
horizontal scaling requires planning
your entire stack from ground up. It
requires changes in our code as compared
to vertical scaling which only means we
go to our infrastructure management
dashboard and we just add more capacity
and more CPU cores and more memory to
our instance as compared to horizontal
scaling where we have to plan from the
ground up. It will affect our code, it
will affect our infrastructure and it
will affect our entire stack. In
horizontal scaling, we have to ensure
statelessness which means that it does
not matter which server the request goes
to. Let's say this is our internet and
our users communicate via their browser
and through internet our servers get the
requests. And what we are saying is it
does not matter what server ends up
getting a particular request. The result
should always be the same. Which means
even if one of these servers get
deleted. Let's say we get rid of B. Even
in that case A combined with C and D
should have the exact same behavior.
That's what we mean by statelessness. No
instance of our server should hold any
piece of information which is not
accessible by all the instances. Which
means that any kind of data if we need
to persist any kind of data then that
should live somewhere here outside of
all our servers which can be accessed by
any instance of our server. Okay, that's
pretty much what we mean by
statelessness. And a couple of examples
of where we exactly use this
statelessness property. One is sessions.
In our typical authentication flow, when
a user comes, they enter their password,
they enter their email and our server
gets that request, it checks whatever
authentication procedure and finally it
has successfully authenticated the user.
It creates a session for that user and
it saves the session ID in the user's
browser cookie and also it saves the
session somewhere in the server so that
the next time a new request comes with
the session ID cookie it can check the
stored session and it can match with the
ID and it can verify the user's
identity. That's how a typical state
full authentication works. Now if let's
say for our horizontal scaling scenario
we have three instances of our server A
B and C and the user while
authenticating it communicated with the
instance A of our server and instance A
created a session stored the cookie in
the user's browser and created a session
variable or the session session instance
but what it did it stored the session
information inside the memory which
means it had something like an array and
it stored the users information here
along with other users information but
the instance B and instance C since this
is an in-memory data structure they
don't have access to this and in turn
what happens because we have a
horizontal scaling setup and we have not
discussed the load balancer part but
next time the user requests the request
ends up with the instance B now B does
not have access to the session
information of this user since the user
authenticated with instance A and
instance say stored information inside
its own memory. Now what happens? B
throws a 401 error and it says that you
have to authenticate first which creates
a very confusing a very frustrating user
experience for our user. So for any kind
of session related information that is a
clear use case of the property of
statelessness. So instead of storing it
inside its memory what instance A should
have done it should have stored it in a
inmemory database storage but but it
should use something like radius and
this radius instance should be
accessible by all the instances so that
the next time a new request comes to
instance B what B can do it can check in
the radius instance since the instance A
after authenticating the user saved the
session information inside radius and
since the radius instance is accessible
to all the instances B can make sure
that B can verify that the user is
already authenticated and it will be
successfully able to process that
request and this is how statelessness
property helps with session related use
cases similarly if we let's say talk
about file storage same use case user A
uploaded a file and because of our
horizontal scaling setup the first
request ended up with instance A what
instance A did it took the file and it
saved it in its own storage SSD or
whatever storage it has it just saved
that file inside its own storage and
because of that the next request when it
landed on instance C this C did not have
access to that and it threw an error. In
this case again to support our
horizontal scaling architecture instead
of storing it inside the file storage of
instance A it should upload it to some
kind of object storage something like S3
or cloudflare R2 or maybe their onremise
menu instance whatever but storage and
object storage ideally which is
accessible by all the instances. So this
kind of pattern will keep repeating but
the intuition is very clear. Once you
have decided that you are going with
horizontal scaling you have to make sure
that at every point of time at your code
level you have to make sure that no
piece of information no piece of file
nothing should be saved inside a
particular instance. Everything should
be centralized. So for in-memory
database you should use something like
radius. for file uploads S3 or any kind
of blob storage. Same way for databases
instead of using something like SQLite
and saving the DB file in your own
server you should use something like
centralized SQLite or posgress or RDS
whatever that is the thumb rule
basically if you're using horizontal
scaling make sure that no piece of
information it's stored in a single
instance and always think about the
statelessness property of your whole
architecture. Okay. Now let's talk about
load balancer. We have been delaying it
for too long even though we have
mentioned it so many times. Load
balancers are one of the very important
and one of the mandatory components of a
horizontal scaling architecture and
we'll see why without a load balancer
the setup of horizontal scaling is
almost impossible. In fact, it starts by
thinking about a load balancer by
setting up a load balancer. The
intuition is very simple if you think
about it. So we have already said that
in horizontal scaling we have multiple
instances of our server again repeating
the same thing and let's say these are
our users who want to communicate and
they are each communicating through a
web browser and this is the internet
internet and these browsers are making
requests through the internet. Now at
this point if you think about it if we
have multiple instances of our server at
what point in our whole stack do we
decide that when a user makes a
particular request which instance do we
send that request to how do we decide
and more importantly where exactly do we
decide where exactly do we make that
decision and that's exactly where the
role of load balancers come in. So you
can imagine a load balancer at somewhere
around this point. In short form we call
it LB a load balancer. So again the
solution is pretty simple. All the
requests that are coming from all the
clients from all our users they all go
to our load balancer instead of going to
our servers directly. They all go to the
load balancer. Now load balancer what it
does takes all those requests and there
is some amount of logic here where it
decides which instance should it forward
this particular request to and we'll
talk about this particular logic but
after it decides which instance it
should send this particular request to
it just redirects those requests using a
piece of logic using a using a few
algorithms and the server instance takes
the request they process it and return
the response in whatever form that we
are sending and the load balancer again
takes that and returns in the same HTTP
connection. That part is pretty
straightforward. The load balancer is
pretty much a middleman which takes the
requests from the internet and forwards
them to our server instances, takes the
responses back and sends them back. The
important part is this the piece of
logic where it decides to which instance
exactly should we forward this
particular request. That's what we call
as the load balancer algorithm. The idea
is simple here. Our load balancer wants
to decide which server it should send
the request to. The first and the
simplest kind of algorithm that we have
is the roundroin. Round dropping which
works in a way. Let's say this is our
load balancer and these are our servers.
So for roundroin algorithm it sends the
requests in a rotating order. What that
means is let's say the first request
comes this is the internet and this is
getting all the requests here. The first
request comes and it sends that to
server one. Second one to server B and
third one to server C. These are A, B,
C. Okay. And the fourth one comes again
it goes to server A, B and C for the
sixth one and the cycle continues.
That's why we call it a roundroin
fashion or a rotating order of sending
requests. And this kind of algorithm the
roundrobin algorithm works best in a
setup where the requests that are being
received by the load balancer they are
similar kind in the sense the the the
cost of those requests the kind of
operations that we are performing the
server is performing like database
operations or Q operations whatever they
are roughly the same kind and the
servers hold the same amount of capacity
each have let's say 4 GB of RAM and
let's say two cores of CPU. If we have
this kind of setup, then a very simple
roundroin algorithm for our load
balancer works like we can get through a
lot of traffic with a simple algorithm.
But consider we have two kinds of
requests. Let's say request one and in
red we have also request two. request
one what it does it does a very simple
database read operation select operation
some kind of select star from users etc
right let's say fetching the user
profile which performs roughly depending
on which region your database in where
are your users but on an average you can
say takes around 200 to 300 millconds
but then we have our request two type
which is a which we consider as an
expensive request and what do we mean by
expensive request. Let's say after
getting the request, it has to make an
HTTP call to an external server. Let's
say something like elastic search or
you're sending an email some kind of
external server which is not our own
server. It has to make a call to an
external server. After getting the
response, it has to make a database
write operation. The right operation
happens on a very big table which has a
lot of rows and a lot of indices. Also
as we already know indices even though
they help speed up select operations
help speed up our join operations but
every time we do a write operation any
kind of modification like update or
inserting a new row it has to update all
the indices of our databases. So let's
say we have a couple of indices here and
every write operation is expensive
because of that. So all in all this
whole API call with the external service
call the database write operation and
everything it takes around 2 seconds to
respond. Now our load balancer since it
is using a simple roundroin algorithm it
sends the request in a pretty mindless
way. Let's say it got the request in
this order. The first request was of
request type one. The second one was of
request type two. The third one again
request type two. The fourth one was
again request type one. And since the
load balancer has no idea what kind of
request that we are dealing with or any
kind of intelligent logic to route the
request, it will keep sending without
realizing all the expensive requests to
a single server and there is a chance
that this particular server will
eventually crash if a skew like this
happens in our request traffic. So there
is a different variation of the round
robin algorithm. Let's say this is again
our load balancer. We have our servers
here A, B and C. And the load balancer
is sending the requests in a roundrobin
fashion. But there is a variation which
is called weighted weighted roundroin
which means that let's say our server A
has 8 GB of RAM and four cores of CPU
and server B has again 4 GB of RAM, two
core CPU. C also has 4 GB of RAM, two
core CP. If we have a setup like this,
what we can do? We can configure our
load balancer in a weighted roundrod
robin fashion so that it sends twice as
many requests to server A as compared to
the other servers. So if it gets a
request burst eight requests first it
will send two requests to server A then
one request to server B then one request
to server C then again two requests to
server A and so on. So server A will
always receive twice as many requests.
Since server A has more amount of
capacity to deal with the request to
process those requests. But even if you
have this kind of setup, the load
balancer still cannot decide
intelligently what kind of request
should be sent to which server. So we
have a different algorithm for our load
balancer which we can consider a little
smarter than the roundroin algorithm
which is called leash connections. And
the way it works is again we have a load
balancer and three servers instances A,
B and C. And again we have all the three
servers with the same amount of capacity
4 GB RAM and two CPU codes. And we are
getting all the requests here. But the
way this particular algorithm works is
instead of sending the request
mindlessly in a rotating order, what the
load balancer does, it checks which
server currently holds the least number
of active connections and depending on
that it will send requests to the other
server. And since you already know that
the HTTP protocol, the one which we
typically use in our backend front end
connections, it works on a request and
response cycle. The client sends a
request and the server sends a response
back with a code something like 200 400
or whatever and the client the browser
it sends the request and waits for the
response and while it waits for that
response we call that as an active
connection. the HTTP connection and
behind the scenes the TCP connection is
active while the server is processing
while the server is making that external
API call while the server is uh doing
that database write operation and
whatever heavy operations that the
server is performing at that point the
connection is still waiting for the
server's response and after the server
is done it sends a response back and the
connection is closed and depending on
whether you are using HTTP2 HTTP 3 the
connection closing the connection
multiplexing those logic will be
different but in a very simple manner if
you are talking about HTTP 1.1 the
server will send the response back and
the connection will be closed. So for
the least connections algorithm how it
works is for expensive operations the
connection will stay active for a longer
amount of time. So let's say we again
have two types of requests the request
one which is a very lightweight request
type and the request two which is a
heavy request type. So let's imagine the
first request that the load balancer
sends is the server A. Since when all
the servers are started, none of the
servers have any amount of active
connections at that point. The load
balancer can choose any servers in a
random order. So for the first request,
it chooses the server instance A and the
request type is obviously the request
type two which takes 2 seconds. Then
comes the next request which is of the
request type one. And then the load
balancer checks the server instance B
and the server instance C are empty and
they have zero number of active
connections. So the second request which
is the request type one goes to server
instance B. And if there is a third
request which is again the request type
one, it goes to server C. Then comes the
fourth request. And by the time the
fourth request comes and since we
already know that the request type one
is a lightweight request which resolves
in let's say around 200 millconds. So by
the time the next request comes the
server A is still serving the request
type two since it is a heavy API call
and the connection is still active. But
by the time the next request arrived
which is the request number four either
server B or server C were done with the
initial request and their connection
went to zero. So the next request will
go to either server B or server C. And
since server A is already dealing with a
heavy API call it will not be sent more
request to process. So by tweaking our
algorithm to consider the active
connections, we can make it decide
intelligently which server should get
the next request which performs a little
better than just using the roundrobin
algorithm which just sends the request
in a rotating order. There is also a
variation on top of the list connections
algorithm the weighted version of it
which means that we'll use the same
algorithm but again the server
capacities will change. Instead of all
of the server instances having the same
capacity, let's say server A has 8 GB
RAM, four core CPU and B and C has 4 GB
RAM and two core CPU. So it will use the
same algorithm but the server A the
instance A will receive twice as many
requests by using the same algorithm.
And similarly we have other load
balancer algorithms. Algorithms like
least response time which means that the
load balancer will check which servers
or which server instances are returning
responses much faster and they will try
to send more requests to those servers
and in turn the servers which are
sending slower responses which are
already struggling with the resources
they will get less number of resources.
Same way we also have resource-based
algorithms which will check which server
has currently high amount of CPU or high
amount of memory or RAM usage and the
servers which have less amount of
resource usage the CPU or RAM they will
receive more number of requests right
similarly there are other algorithms but
the idea is always the same the load
balancer depending on some piece of
logic it decides which server instance
it should send The next response to the
next interesting question that you might
ask is let's say here we have a load
balancer and three server instances A B
and C and let's say the load balancer
was following the roundroin algorithm or
least connections algorithm whatever
whichever you want to take and for some
reason our server A crashed it got more
amount of request because of our simpler
roundroin algorithm or maybe some kind
of infrastructure misconfiguration
happened and server A crashed while
using the list connections algorithm and
it is not able to respond to any more
requests since this machine is
completely stopped. It is not working.
Now if the load balancer is using
roundroin algorithm or if the load
balancer is using list connections or
any other algorithm what will happen if
it is using the roundroin algorithm it
will keep sending the request in
rotating order. Let's say first A second
B second C then A then B then C. So
every request that goes to the server A
or the server instance A the request
will obviously fail. The client will get
something like 502 or 503 and those
clients those users will keep getting
these errors and the other users they
will not get any errors because their
requests are going to server instance B
or server instance C. But again since
this is roundroin the next request of
the user whose request was previously
served by server instance B the next
time it might go to server A and they
might also face the same errors which
can quickly become a very frustrating
user experience. So how do we actually
solve this problem? How do load
balancers they solve this problem of a
particular server instance going dead or
a particular server instance not being
able to serve any more requests. So
that's where we have this concept called
L checks which is a very simple but
effective technique. What happens we
have our load balancer here servers here
and these are the typical requests that
are coming from our users that the load
balancer is forwarding to the server and
returning the responses back to our
users. While that is happening, what the
load balancer does, it keeps sending its
own request, test request, a very
simple, let's say a get endpoint to all
the servers. Let's say every second,
every second. While sending these actual
requests, the requests that are coming
from our users, it also sends a test
request every second to all the server
instances. It keeps sending us. And in
the response, it expects a success
response, which means something like 200
201. But of course the practice is to
send a 200 response. So if the server is
online, if the server is currently
processing request, it will obviously
get that test request and it will send
200 response back immediately because
usually it's just a test request. No
kind of heavy operation happens here. So
it does not really cause any kind of
load on our instances because of us
sending this test request every second.
But the moment let's say server A the
instance A went down and the next second
when the load balancer sent a test
request to the server A it did not send
a 20 response and by default the server
the load balancer got something like 502
response from the HTTP client and the
moment it gets a error response or any
kind of response which is not the 200
series responses it will immediately put
this server under blacklist. list or
some kind of list which means that we
will not be sending any kind of user
requests which are the requests that are
marked in blue here that are coming from
our actual users. Those requests will
not be sent to this particular instance
from now on. So all the user requests
they will go to either server B or
server C depending on whatever algorithm
that you are using round robin list
connections or whatever but meanwhile it
will keep sending this test request to
this server instance otherwise how will
it know that this server instance has
come back online it is able to serve
responses now so these test requests
they will keep going here and after it
gets a successful response something
like 200 then it will remove that
instance from blacklist and from the
next request onwards it will also send
these blue requests the requests that
are coming from our users to server A.
So using this simple technique called
health checks our load balancer can
decide whether a server is healthy or a
server is able to cater to our users
requests. So that's pretty much all
about load balancers and horizontal
scaling that I wanted to talk about. Of
course, it's not comprehensive in any
way, but it's good to know what are the
components that play an important role
while you are thinking about scaling
your backends and load balancers are a
very big part of scaling your backends.
That's a very brief introduction but
enough so that you can continue your own
reading on load balancers. Okay, next
let's talk about database scaling. Now
scaling our application, our back end,
whatever code that we write our
application, scaling that part is or
becomes straightforward once you
externalize state. That's what we
learned, right? Because the clear winner
was obviously horizontal scaling, not
vertical scaling. And the key to
horizontal scaling was externalizing
your state. Instead of limiting any kind
of information, any kind of state or any
kind of connections, any kind of state
to a particular instance of the server,
you externalize it. Which means you do
not keep any kind of cache limited to a
particular server. You do not keep any
kind of files limited to a server
instance. You do not keep any kind of
session data or any kind of information
that you can think of. You externalize
everything. You use radius. You use
databases for all the session related
information and use a object file
storage like S3 for storing your files
instead of keeping in your own local
instance. Right? All the stuff that we
discussed. Once you externalize your
state, you add more servers behind your
load balancers and your capacity will
increase linearly the more number of
servers that you can add that you can
afford. But while you're doing that, the
part that becomes a little difficult to
scale or a little tricky to scale is
your database, which is a stateful part
of your architecture. Because your
database, they cannot be duplicated the
way you just duplicated your server.
Each database they hold some amount of
data, a lot of data in their files, in
their local storage. And that data again
must be consistent. Which means if you
have multiple database instances, when a
request arrives and that particular
database instance receives that request,
the data it sends back, that should be
exactly the same as the other instance
of the database sending the data back
and making this coordination work.
That's what makes scaling databases a
very tricky part of scaling your overall
backend architecture. So of course we
already have a couple of solutions, a
couple of tried and tested solutions in
our industry for scaling our database
component. The stateful component of our
backend architecture. The first one and
the obvious one in most of the use cases
is called read replicas. Now read
replicas it's a very simple and an
intuitive architecture of scaling
databases. So here is our single
database instance and since the number
of servers since going with horizontal
scaling they are growing because we want
to cater to millions and billions of
user traffic. So all these servers they
are still dealing with the same database
instance right we were able to scale our
application code our processing logic
but our storage logic which is the
database component which we interact
with to store and retrieve data that is
still a single instance and eventually
this particular database which is again
a server let's say it has 4 GB or RAM
and four cores of CPU this is still a
server and eventually it will run lot of
resource to cater to all these requests
that your back end is demanding from
your database. So we also have to figure
out some way of scaling our database.
Read replicas are one way to do that to
scale your database operations across
multiple instances. And since database
are a stateful component in our
architecture, we cannot just add more
instances, right? They will have all
this problem of data consistency. So one
popular architecture that we have is the
read replica and this is how it works.
We have one database instance which we
call as primary or parent whatever or
master. There are multiple terminologies
here. You can call it primary or master
instance whatever. This one is the
primary database instance and we have
three replicas which are secondary
instances or child instance or slave
instances. Again depends on the
terminology but the idea is all these
instances of our database they will hold
the data but these instances they will
only cater to read requests which means
select ones. You can only read data from
these instances. You cannot write data
back to these instances. So that is the
number one rule. And typically what we
do we create these replicas or instances
of our database which holds all the data
that the primary holds and we spread it
across the world. So if you have users
in India and US and China then you can
have one primary instance the primary
database in US and you can have three
read replicas one in India one in China
and one in Japan etc. So users that are
sending request from those countries of
course assuming that you also have your
backends spread across these countries
then those backend instances combined
with those database instances will be
able to cater to the users of those
countries and in turn the requests and
the responses will be faster as compared
to all the requests coming to a single
instance of US. So that is there there
are two benefits of reader replicas. One
is low usage or less amount of load that
your primary database instance has to
take up and the second one is latency.
Your back end will experience less
amount of latency. So read replicas are
obviously a very good solution. all your
read queries and if we take a look at
most of the applications at least SAS
applications where the context of
backend comes primarily 90 or let's say
even if you are being conservative 70%
of the requests that we receive are read
requests the back end mostly does select
requests to our database right those are
read requests and all those 70% of the
requests will be served by these
replicas read replicas And the rest of
the 30% of the requests that are things
like insert or update or delete all
these requests any kind of a write
operations based request they will go to
our primary instance. So initially our
database had to deal with 100% of the
requests. Now it came down to only 30%.
So the resource utilization will be much
lower. the resource load will be much
lower and we were able to scale our
databases linearly. Now, of course, it
does not come without its trade-offs or
problems. The problem is consistency.
And what do we mean by consistency?
Let's take an example. Let's say we have
a user here. We have a user here from
their browser. They just updated their
name in their user profile page. And
since it is a write operation, that
particular request by the back end,
let's say there is a back end here, back
end instance, that particular request
went to our primary database instance or
our primary replica which handles any
kind of write operation, right? And the
moment they updated their name, they
refreshed the page. And since page
refreshing means fetching the user
profile data back from our database and
sending it to the client to the browser
the request type is a read request. It
is not a write request and that
immediately after let's say only a few
milliseconds 200 millconds the request
obviously went to a read replica. Now
let's assume that this interaction
happened from India and the primary
database instance that is in US. So the
write operation happened in our primary
database instance. So this particular
database instance currently holds the
updated data the updated name of the
user. So let's say the user changed the
name from A to A. Now at this point of
time at this particular 10 milliseconds
range only this primary database holds
the updated data. Of course if we have
this read replica based architecture
there will obviously be some kind of
replication algorithm right we cannot go
into the depths of the replication
algorithm and all but most of the modern
databases posgress MySQL SQLite on all
these databases they have native
features to support replication right so
you can imagine there is some algorithm
some kind of setup happening here using
which the data from our primary database
flows back to the read replicas, right?
It makes sense intuitively if you have
this kind of architecture. If these
replicas are a copy of our primary
databases, then there has to be some
kind of mechanism when any kind of
updated data flows back to all these
read replicas. But even if that
mechanism is in place, we still have to
consider physics. The distance between
these two servers, these two physical
servers from US to India, there is some
amount of latency there. let's say 200
milliseconds or 300 milliseconds because
at the end of the day our data travels
through optic fiber cables from under
the sea or any kind of medium so that
one server can send some data to another
server and the physical distance between
two servers have the largest role to
play when it comes to latency. We cannot
beat that. We cannot beat physics. So
the distance between US and India
assuming the fastest medium assuming the
latency is 200 millconds. So the
replication lag what we call the
technological term for this is called
replication lag which is 200
milliseconds. But this particular
interaction usually in our client apps
what happens usually in our form fields
especially in our form fields we make an
update to that particular field and we
click on the save button and the moment
we click on the save button the request
goes to our server. Our server does the
write operation and it sends something
like a successful response either 20 0
or 201 if it created a resource. Now the
moment it receives a successful response
if we are talking about SP single page
applications or server rendered pages
here the client framework it issues a
get request which means we want to fetch
the latest form field data for this user
profile. So the moment we get a
successful response in that millisecond
only we fire another get request and
since this is a read request it goes to
the read replica and since it has not
been 200 milliseconds so the replication
is not complete. This particular read
replica does not have the updated user
data the updated user's name which is
AB. So even though our client said that
your username has been updated, your
name has been updated from A to A but in
the next moment the read replica will
send an outdated response which is A. So
that particular user interaction will
become a very confusing or if it is a
more sensitive operation something like
payment related operation or invoice
related operation it can also cause a
lot of damage to our application. So
this problem of consistency is the
biggest challenge when we are talking
about read replica based architecture
for database scaling. Of course over the
time there has been a lot of proposed
solutions and a lot of implemented
solutions to deal with this problem of
consistency in a read replica based
architecture. A couple of them are if
some kind of write operation happens. So
that will go to our primary database
instance right and the right operation
happened on the user profile entity the
user profile model the user profile
database table whatever. So one solution
that we can do is since users table was
updated for this particular interaction
whatever read query that comes after
that particular write query we route it
to our primary instance instead of
routing it to our read replicas we route
it to our primary instance. That is one
solution that you can implement routing
requests intelligently. Another thing
that you can do is you can track this
replication lag that we talked about
which is like 200 milliseconds to copy
updated data from our primary instance
to our read replicas. That latency is
called the replication lag. So you can
keep tracking this replication lag. So
average something like 200 250
milliseconds. And while that is
happening you can block all your read
queries or you can make all your read
queries wait until the replication is
complete and only after the replication
is complete you send the updated data
back in the response. So that is another
solution that you can implement. Apart
from that you can also architect your
front end in a way that the updated data
is not fetched that instant only. there
is some amount of planned latency there
after let's say 300 milliseconds you
fire the next get request. So all these
different kinds of solutions that we
need to implement and the kind of
solution that you will implement depends
on what kind of tradeoff that you are
willing to do. Every time you are
talking about distributed systems the
one that we talked about here the read
replica based architecture which is a
distributed system concept. So every
time you are talking about a distributed
systembased solution, you always have to
make some amount of trade-off and most
of the time it is about consistency. How
do you make sure that all of your
instances have the updated information
about your server or your users? But
anyway, all these modern database
providers like let's RDS, Google Cloud,
SQL and these manage database providers,
they make it very easy to implement read
replicas and to implement read replicas
in particular regions. It just takes a
few configuration flags or a couple of
toggles in UI and your read replicas
will be ready. And they also have a lot
of tried and tested robust solutions to
deal with all these different kind of
consistency based problems for read
replicas. You as a backend engineer will
not have to worry about these deep
infralevel problems. But it is still
nice to know that these kinds of
trade-offs always happen in your
infrastructure based setups especially
when you're talking about database
scaling. Now moving on, another famous
technique that will keep coming up
whenever we are talking about database
scaling is sharding also known as
partitioning. Okay, sharding basically
means that let's say you have a orders
table. you are an e-commerce based
application something like Amazon,
Flipkart or whatever and you have a
database table where you store orders
information and of course for an
e-commerce based application you get
thousands of orders millions of orders
every day. So your orders table
eventually becomes billions of rows. And
whenever you want to fetch some data
from this orders table, you run
something like select star from orders
where user id equals to five. Right? If
you want to fetch all the orders of a
particular user, user went to their
orders page and you want to fetch all
the orders of that user. So you'll run a
query like this. But running a
particular query like this on a table
which has billions and hundreds of
billions of rows, it can take a long
amount of time and even though you have
index implemented for let's say the user
ID column, it will still take a lot of
time because the volume of rows billions
and hundreds and thousands of billions
of row that we're talking about if you
are a very famous e-commerce based
company. to deal with query latency.
That is the first problem that we have.
The second is obviously we are talking
about database scaling and database
scaling in the context of scaling so
that our databases can handle a large
amount of requests in a short time which
means more resource which more resource
means more instances of our database
right. So scaling instances that is the
second problem. So sharding solves both
of these problems. And how does it
solve? So let's take the orders table.
And what do we do? We shard this table.
We partition this table. Which means we
divide this table. Say this is the whole
table. And instead of billions, let's
imagine just to understand this concept.
It has 10 rows, right? And if you
imagine one row as a representation of 1
billion rows. So it has 10 million rows
but we are talking in the context of 1
to 10. So it has 10 rows and what we do
and what we did we divided this into two
parts. Two parts and this is one
database instance and 6 to 10. This is
the second database instance. So we took
the orders table and we divided the
table in a way that they are physically
in two separate database instances.
Right? And how did we divide it? So
every time you think about sharding one
of the very tricky problems is figuring
out what should be the sharding key
which means that what should be the
parameter according to which you can
divide this table. How do you actually
decide that this particular data should
live in this instance and this
particular amount of data this should
live in this instance. You have to come
up with some kind of criteria that we
will divide according to dash. Now in
this instance what you can do is in
first database instance for first
physical database you will only hold the
orders of January to June and in the
second database instance you will hold
the orders from June to December. Right
now this order date has become your
starting key. Now what is the benefit?
You have two database instance, two
physical database instance which has the
clear benefit that two database instance
can serve more amount of requests per
second. Right? If this is our internet,
this is our server instances. Then since
we have two databases now, they can
handle more amount of requests. So that
solves second problem. Now the first
problem which was query latency since
instead of dealing with 10 rows instead
of dealing with 10 billion rows this
particular database instance only has to
now deal with 5 billion rows or five
rows. So query latency also in turn
becomes less because the amount of rows
become less. Now of course this was a
very simple example to show the concept
but depending on your volume you can
also shard this by month also. For
January, you can keep one instance. For
February, you can keep another shard.
For March, you can keep another shard.
Right? So, in your back end or in some
place in the your in your routing layer,
in your backend in your database routing
layer, you can decide and here before
making the request, you decide at this
point that which particular shard holds
this data and you send the request to
that particular shard and it sends the
response back and you return it back to
the user. So that's pretty much what
sharding is which is basically means
dividing your data into multiple
physical database instances instead of
keeping all the data in one table you
divide the table physically right so
those are two important concepts that
you will keep hearing replication and
sharding read replicas and database
shards of course there are a lot of
technical complexities behind the scenes
of how to interact with them how to
create the charts but now we are just
focusing on the concepts the things that
you should know about but to actually
learn them how to implement them how to
understand them in a deep technical way
you can do your own reading now moving
on talking about current times which is
current time in the sense right now it's
2025 December the current trend when it
comes to scaling databases are
distributed databases right some of the
famous examples are planet scale which
uses pus behind the scenes which is
primarily MISQL
based database. We also have neon when
we are talking about posgress. Neon is
purely written in rust and it is
considered as a serverless database.
Similarly, we also have cockroach DB. We
also have Yugabyte, right? A lot of
distributed databases which handle all
these problems. the problem of sharding,
the problem of replication, the problem
of distributed transactions and
everything all the complexities that
arise when we talk about database
scaling they automatically handle that.
So talking in a realistic scenario if
you are a backend engineer you just go
ahead whatever database provider that
you want to use with whether it is RDS
or whether it is neon planet scale
whatever database that you want to use
obviously it is never recommended
especially when you're starting out
especially if you don't have very deep
expertise in databases and database
administration or database scaling then
you should not roll out your own
database infrastructure because as we
have already talked about the
replication sharding and the database
backup is another problem. How do you
keep your users data safe and in
multiple places? So there are a lot of
complexities when it comes to databases
and obviously it is not recommended that
you roll out your own database
infrastructure even though the fact that
you know all these concepts is good and
it is advised but should not roll out
your own database infrastructure unless
you know what you're doing exactly. So
realistically you will just choose
whatever database provider that you want
to go with depending on their features
depending on the pricing depending on
your team's preference AWS neon plan
whatever and you'll just sign up create
a database and you'll get a URL of the
database username password whatever
credentials the database has you just
plug it in in your database in your back
end and you'll start interacting with it
right you do not have to think about
replication you do not have to think
about sharding and anything. But you
have to know this concept so that you
can go into your database console, your
database provider console and you can
configure things. You can configure that
how frequently you want to take database
backups in what regions of the world
that you want to keep read replicas and
how do you want to plan your sharding.
The actual activity of replication, the
actual activity of sharding, the actual
activity of distributing your replicas
that you don't have to do. But you still
have to understand what all these terms
mean, what all these concepts, what all
these techniques do so that you can
express how do you want to configure
your database. That's why it was
important that we talked about database
scaling. Even though in a realistic
scenario, you will not actually have to
do any of this as long as you understand
what all these terms mean. So far we
have discussed caching within your data
centers. But there is another layer of
caching that we have not discussed yet
and that layer operates on the global
level. We think about geography when we
think about this layer of caching and we
call that cydians content delivery
networks. And to understand why CDNs
matter, I actually have a video about
CDNs in depth, which is of course in a
different context. I was talking about
how serverless platforms like Versel
work. But if you want to learn more
about Cydians, if you want to understand
cydians in a much more technically
deeper way, then please watch that
video. We'll also talk about cydians in
this video but not in that much depth
since that video was completely about
cydians. Okay. To understand why cydians
matter, why do we need cydians in the
first place, you have to understand one
fundamental constraint or one limitation
of our world or physics per se which is
the speed of light. Now light travels at
around 200,000
kilometer per second through fiber optic
cables. We are not talking about lights
speed in space but in fiber optic cables
which are at the end of the day the
speed of our internet. We cannot cross
this speed ever because whatever data
that is transmitted from one country to
another from one part of the world to
another end of the day it is all going
through under sea cables and that
happens at this speed. This is our cap
200,000 km/s.
So if a request is going from Tokyo to a
server which is in Virginia or North
Virginia is the region US East one where
you'll find most of our commercial
applications most of your famous servers
are hosted in they have instances there
is US east one which is north Virginia
for this request to make a round trip
roundrip in the sense to send a request
from the browser and getting the
response back from the server. to make
this whole round trip which is roughly
around 20,000
km and at the speed of light in optical
fiber cables that's roughly around 100
milliseconds and this is our cap this is
our physics cap which means no amount of
optimization no amount of technology at
least the kind of technology that we
have access to these days it cannot beat
this for making a roundtrip the minimum
amount of latency that the user is going
to face for a request response sound
trip is going to be 100 millconds for a
user based in Tokyo. And 100
milliseconds honestly does not sound
much but this we are talking about only
the round trip of sending the request
and getting the response back. There is
still stuff happening after getting the
request. The first thing obviously is
the routing layer and the routing layer
is pretty fast if you think about it.
Mostly it's a regular expression based
routing depending on which resource the
user has sent a request to and depending
on that the respective handler picks it
up but after the handler whichever
function that is supposed to deal with
this particular request picks it up the
first step that happens is a des
serialization process which means taking
the HTTP message and deserializing it
into the data structure of that pro
programming language. If it is something
like NodeJS, it'll become a JavaScript
object from the JSON. And same for if
it's a go programming based back end, it
will become a strct etc. Right? And
usually this des serialization process
of JSON takes some time depending on how
large the payload is, right? And that is
still not the largest cause of latency.
That is just the entry point. After
that, we have our service layer. We run
any some amount of business logic and
that typically involves dealing with our
database and databases again depending
on what is the distance between your
server and your database and assuming
the best case scenario. So server and
database are in the same region in the
same data center or similar kind of
setup. Still for a midlevel to complex
query it might take somewhere around 50
milliseconds to 100 milliseconds. On top
of that if there are any external API
calls for that particular API then again
that might cause another 200
milliseconds. If you combine all that
that 100 milliseconds which is the
minimum amount of latency that a user
from Tokyo was about to face that
quickly becomes somewhere close to 500
to 800 millconds right so even if you
forget about all this which we already
discussed what kind of optimization that
we can do on database level what kind of
automation that we can do on the caching
level using things like inmemory caches
like radius etc etc the last cause of
latency it all still boils boils down to
the physical distance between your user
and your server the geographical gap and
this is exactly the problem that CDNs
are supposed to solve. So what we do
instead of the requests that originated
from Tokyo instead of going to US
instead of going to the US server what
it does we place the CDN edge locations
or also called as pops points of
presence in the same region let's say in
Tokyo. So instead of traveling all the
way to 20,000 km for the whole round
trip, this will come down to something
like 100 to 200 km and the latency will
come down from 100 millconds to
something like 2 to 3 millconds. That is
a huge performance win. Even though from
human perceived time 100 millconds in 2
3 mconds does not make a lot of
difference but since we are talking
about scaling and performance this is a
huge difference coming from 100 to 2
millconds. So that is one advantage of
CDNs. We take a particular piece of
content and we cache it at CDN and we
place that particular server that
particular node which is going to serve
the content which is going to send the
content back to the user close to the
users. Right? So one obvious win of
using CDNs is the latency latency.
Second is the load and since we are
placing all these CDN nodes these points
of presence closer to users one node in
Tokyo one node in let's say Mumbai
another in Singapore and depending on
where the user's request is coming from
that particular CDN node is going to
send the content. Of course, there is
another layer of logic where we decide
what particular piece of content are we
going to cache in CDN. That is a
different discussion which you can find
in the CDN video. But assuming that we
have already done that, we have already
place this particular piece of content
in CDN. Then the user just requests for
that content and the CDN sends it back.
And because of that our primary server
which is in US let's say it does not get
as much amount of traffic. So the
traffic gets distributed across all the
CDN nodes and it gets 50% less amount of
traffic roughly speaking. So that is
another win of using CDN. Your primary
server is not going to use a lot of
resources. you don't have to worry about
horizontal scaling as frequently if
you're using CDNs and if you are
prioritizing caching your content across
CDN nodes. So the obvious next question
is what can you put in your CDN content
and what kind of content that we usually
put in our CDNs and one obvious starting
point is static content. What do you
mean by static content? things like our
JavaScript bundles or CSS bundles, HTML
files and images and videos, fonts,
right? These kinds of contents, they
don't change as often. Usually when we
deploy our front-end application, that
becomes a bundle of JavaScript, CSS, and
HTML. Assuming that it is a SPA, single
page application, something like React.
We take that bundle and we cache it
across CDN nodes. So when a user
requests for our front-end application
instead of going to the primary server
where uh it gets the request it sends a
request to something like an S3 bucket
and serves it back that particular
request will go to the CDN and since the
CDN is closer to the users that response
will be faster. So that is the idea
since static content does not change as
often caching it in CDN make a lot of
sense and this is typically how we
deploy our SPS single page applications
or static site application like blogs it
etc and also the images fonts etc. These
are also called static content and a
very good candidates for caching in
CDNs. But apart from that, we can also
cache a few API responses. For example,
if you have an e-commerce page and you
have a product catalog and you know that
this catalog is not going to change
anytime soon or as often or as
frequently. Of course when we are using
CDN there are also techniques for
invalidating the cache or in CDN
terminology purging the cache we have
used cloudflare CDN which is one of the
largest CDN providers they have a lot of
mechanisms using you can provide tags to
your CDN content and depending on a
particular condition let's say some data
change or a user uploaded a new blog
then you can take a tag let's say a tag
which had the user ID and all the blogs
of that user. You can take that tag and
you can say that let's purge all the
cache which means delete all the cached
content of this particular user all the
blocks of this user and fetch new data
from our primary server and cach it
again in the CDN. So depending on all
these conditions you can of course
decide when do you remove stuff from
your CDN cache and when do you load new
data. So those conditions are there you
don't have to worry about serving old
content etc etc. That's a different
strategy of how to manage CDN content.
So API responses are also cached
depending on our use cases. A third use
case of CDNs especially the cloud flares
USB when they are selling their CDN is
the security perspective. One of the
famous modern-day attacks are DOS
attacks, which means that an attacker
has control over a lot of computers,
over the internet, a lot of bots using
some kind of malware. And the attacker
uses all these bots spread across the
whole world. Let's say it has control
over around 20,000 bots using some kind
of malware. So what it does if it wants
to target your server, it will write
some kind of script. So that let's say
this is your server and computers nodes
from all over the world will start
sending traffic to your server and since
our servers have a particular limit on
the amount of resources eventually those
limits will be crossed and either our
server is going to crash if there are
some hard limits or if we have
configured horizontal scaling all the
advanced scaling techniques then what
our servers will do it will keep
spinning up new instances to deal with
all that traffic and in turn will incur
a heavy amount of charge. So you will
like $50,000 for one day because all
these new instances were spun up and it
catered to a large amount of traffic. So
you will either face damage in the sense
your server will crash or financial
damage. So DOS is still very relevant.
You every other day you read in the news
that this particular server was attacked
with the DOS etc. So Cloudflare CDN one
of its offerings is you have your server
and you place the Cloudflare CDN in
front of your servers. So all the
traffic goes through Cloudflare and then
it goes to your server. If there is some
cache content it returns from this point
otherwise it sends to your server. And
this cloudfare CDN layer it also works
as a security layer in the sense if in a
very short time span it gets a lot of
traffic they have a very advanced
methodologies to detect these kinds of
attacks because they've been working on
this for years. So the moment they
detect this attack there are certain
number of steps that they trigger things
like asking all your users to captures
right all the suspicious users etc etc
and on top of that all this traffic it
cannot really do any damage to your
servers because there is another
additional layer in front of your
servers and since Cloudflare CDN is one
of the largest CDN providers in the
whole world all this traffic gets
distributed across their nodes so no
serious damage can be done even though
the traffic is in terabytes terabytes or
pabytes of data because Cloudflare's CDN
network is so large. So that is the
third advantage of using CDN. Another
interesting thing that keeps coming up
while we are talking about CDN is edge
computing. Now traditionally the word
edge used to mean that so we have our
CDNs we have our users in Tokyo, India,
Singapore and we have our CDN nodes for
all these regions and these nodes are
usually called edge nodes because they
are at the edge of the network right
because we interact with our internet
service providers ISPs and usually CDNs
are strategically placed in
collaboration with our ISPs so that when
a user request triggers at the edge of
the network. At the first point of
interaction of the network, we place our
CDN nodes and that is the reason the CDN
responses are very fast. They are
strategically placed at the edge of the
network, the first point of the network.
That was the initial use case of this
word in the context of CDNs, the edge
nodes. Now in the modern times, a
different term, a similar sounding term
which causes a lot of confusion is edge
computing. Now edge computing is also in
the context of CDNs. But when we say
edge computing what it means?
Traditionally CDNs have always been used
as a layer for sending static contents
like JavaScript or images or videos etc.
All the static content. So a user from
Tokyo they request a particular video or
they request a front-end application
with bundle of JavaScript CS and HTML.
Your CDN gets that request and
immediately finds the file, sends it
back. There is no processing layer
happening here. There is no complex
processing happening here. You request
the exact file, the name of the file and
the CDN sends it back. It does not think
about it at all. Now what edge computing
means, you send a request and there is
some additional processing happening
here. Then it sends whatever response
that you're expecting. Now this
processing that happens at the CDN layer
at the edge node layer is called edge
computing and since our traditional
servers they are placed in primary data
centers like US east and all the big
regions that we have available in or GCP
these edge nodes or CDN nodes the number
of CDN nodes are and always will be
greater than the number of primary data
centers because primary data centers
they require a lot of resources they
require a lot of geographic
strategy and a lot of investment both
financially and operationally. But since
CDN nodes are placed and created in
collaboration with your ISPs, so ISPs
are primary infrastructure for placing
your CDNs. Even though there are these
big players like Cloudflare and Aless
they have their own CDN infrastructure
in collaboration with ISP but
traditionally speaking CDNs have always
been an infrastructure primarily based
on ISP's infrastructure your internet
service providers and since there are
more number of these CDN edge nodes and
they are very close to users you send a
request to this edge node the processing
happens very quickly even though the
processing itself might take the same
amount of time that our primary data
center or primary service would take.
But since the request and response
roundtrip latency is less, it feels like
our edge computing whatever edge
computing level responses are faster
than our traditional server based
responses and for good reasons. One
solid example of one of the most used
use cases of edge computing is
authentication. So again take the same
example of an us user in Tokyo and our
primary data center in US and for
authentication if we are going stateful
authentication we send whatever session
information that we have using cookies
etc. So the user sends a cookie to the
server. The server checks using the
session ID from the cookie. It checks
from database or radius whether the
cookie is valid or not. The session is
valid or not. And if it is valid, it the
request passes through and if it is not
valid then it sends an error response
something like 401 which is
unauthorized. But the whole round trip
spend around 100 milliseconds just to
get an error response that you are not
authorized to make this request which
seems like a lot of waste of your
bandwidth and your service resources
just to send a rejection. So for this
use case what alternatives have come up
is instead of sending this
authentication based request directly to
your primary server you send it to your
edge node. So this is your edge node
whatever CDN node which is capable of
doing some kind of processing. So you
send it and it checks the same amount of
logic that you would have done in your
server layer you do it at the edge
layer. You check the session information
you check the session ID if it is not
valid instantly send 401. Now instead of
getting a 401 response after 100
millconds, you get it in 2 to 3
millconds and your server was not
disturbed with a lot of unauthorized
based requests and only if this user is
authorized then we let the request pass
to our server. So the server only deals
with legit requests which in turn
reduces a lot of traffic unnecessary
traffic. So that is a very good and
famous use cases of using edge
computing. They can also do a lot of
other things. For example, let's say
they get a request and depending on user
location since the edge nodes they are
very close to the users they know which
region they are serving. So the request
coming from Tokyo they can check the
headers and if the request says that the
user's browser language is something
like Japanese. So instead of sending the
content let's say it's a blog instead of
sending it in English or instead of
doing the localization based
configuration of your website in English
they can directly send a response. This
is a Japanese version of your website
and all of this happens very fast. So
all this users location based
configuration customization and user
preferences. This is also a solid use
case for using edge computing. But one
question that you might have is if edge
computing is so fast and so useful then
why not use everything? Why not use edge
computing for everything? And the reason
for that is constraints. What kind of
constraints that we are talking about?
As I've already said, edge computing or
CDN nodes have always been an
infrastructure of our ISPs. So you can
imagine a request from a user from
Tokyo, it goes through and the first
point of contact is going to be the ISP,
the company which provides you with
internet. So let's say if you're from
India, so a company like Etel or a
company like ACT or whatever ISP that
you're using that gets your request and
they have a number of routing layers,
hobs as you can call it. It goes from
one point then another point and then
another point then eventually it crosses
the undersea cables and goes to another
country then they have another ISP there
and eventually it reaches your server.
Right? So all these routing happens
throughout the way. So traditionally
CDNs are usually let's say an ISP has an
infrastructure here to route the
internet request. So at this particular
infrastructure they'll have some
collaboration with a company like
Cloudflare and they will provide a CDN
level functionality here but their
primary responsibility has always been
routing the internet requests. CDN is
just something they do in collaboration
with all these providers like Cloudfare
and AWS. So the kind of infrastructure
they provide it is not very robust which
means that they have limited amount of
RAM. So instead of having like 8 GB of
RAM or 16 GB of RAM they'll have
something like 1 GB of or one core CPU.
Right? So the resource constraints are a
big problem when we are talking about
edge computing. That is one point. The
second point is the whole idea of edge
computing has always been very low
latency based computing. So one primary
example of edge computing is Cloudflare
workers right one of the most famous
edge computing based infrastructure that
we have available today and Cloudflare
workers they use V8 isolates a
JavaScript runtime from Chrome and they
use this V8 based runtime to process
your request to do any kind of
computations and this edge computing
environment comes with a lot of
constraints like it cannot interact with
your file system it cannot do things
like TCP protocols etc etc. So all these
resource constraint all these runtime
processing constraints are the reason
that we cannot offload everything to CDN
nodes our primary servers are robust
data center infrastructure they have to
be there but we can offload some amount
of logic strategic logic which makes
sense to be placed at the CDN level at
the edge computing level so that the
edge nodes and our primary servers can
work together to provide a very seamless
experience to our users. Things that we
already discussed like authentication or
user customization or validation or
routing which server the request should
go to etc. All these things they are
very good at but they cannot completely
replace our primary servers as of now.
Moving on to our next topic which is
asynchronous processing. Whenever we
talk about reducing the latency of our
backend application, at least reducing
the perceived latency, the kind of
latency that the user faces while
interacting with our application on the
front end side, then asynchronous
processing is typically one of the
solutions that we opt for and it is not
something that we implement at the later
stage. For example, horizontal scaling
is something that we go for at a
particular threshold. Let's say we have
crossed 10,000 users, 50,000 users. When
vertical scaling does not make any
sense, we go for horizontal scaling. But
asynchronous processing is one of those
solutions that we typically opt for at
the start of our application only
because of the very obvious benefits
that it has that we are going to talk
about. What do we mean by asynchronous
processing? Typically what happens, we
have our users, they interact with our
server using a browser. So for a normal
API call, a normal HTTP API call, they
send a request. We do some amount of
processing and we send a response back.
For example, let's say the user is on
their profile page. They updated the
name from A to B. We take that, we call
a DB query by interacting with the
database. We run update update user set
name equals to B returning user do ID
whatever. and that database operation is
successful and only after that database
operation is successful, we send a
response back. We cannot tell the user
that okay your username has been updated
before the database response is
successful. Right? It has to be only
after the database operation is
successful. We can tell the user that
okay this is a 20 response. This is a
successful response which means that
when the user does a refresh when they
hit a refresh page or if you have
automatic reloading of the user profile
page they immediately see this change
their name getting changed from A to B.
So this is a typical experience that we
have in most of our operations. But
there are some kind of operations which
do not have to be synchronous in the
sense synchronous behavior. I'm not
talking about synchronous processing but
synchronous behavior. The users do not
have to see the change immediately after
the response. So for them what we do so
let's take an example in most of our SAS
applications there is a functionality
that you have your workspace or you have
your team if you have used a software
like Jira or notion or pretty much all
the SAS applications these days offer
this functionality of having your own
workspace and team and you can add more
members of your team to your workspace
so that you can all work together work
have access to the same kind of
resources So usually in our front end
there is some kind of UI where you go
and you type the email. Say you want to
invite one atgmail.com
and you hit enter. Okay, invite or
whatever the button is to submit this
request and to invite this user. So the
first thing that happens is obviously
the browser JavaScript converts it into
an STP API call and you get this in your
server. All right. Now in your server
the first layer is routing layer. Then
your handler gets it and it gets the
request body and in turn it finds out
the email that you want to invite user
one atgmail.com. So what would this
processing look like? There are the
obvious layers of validating this
particular request authenticating that
the that user but we'll ignore all that.
Purely focusing on the service layer on
the pure business layer and the database
layer. This is how it would look like.
First using our database we will check
whether this particular user is already
part of this team or not just as a
database level validation layer and once
it passes that the next thing we do we
save this database entry in a table in a
table something like invites table or
team members table or organization users
table depending on how you are
structuring your database in some kind
of table you will add this data this is
the particular email that the user has
invited to and the status of that. There
will be other fields and these are the
primary ones. The status is it is
pending by default. It'll be in pending
state. The user has not accepted the
invite yet. Then accepted then rejected
whatever logic that you have. Okay. Once
that is done, the next phase typically
involves sending an email to this
particular user email user 1@gmail.com
because that's how they'll get the
invite and that's how they'll be able to
come to the platform and accept the
invite. But for that we have to send an
email. So now from your backend server
all this processing is very fast because
you are doing whatever processing that
you have and you are interacting with
your database which is like assuming
closer to your server when talking about
the data center region. So this
typically consists let's say somewhere
around 50 to 80 millconds or max to max
100 millconds. Now after doing all this
we have to send an email. Now to send an
email we have to usually send an make an
API call to an external email provider
something like Mailchimp or send grid or
resend whatever email provider that
you're using they all pretty much do the
same thing they take the email they take
either a template ID or a readym made
HTML template and you make an API call
and they send a successful response back
but this typically since we do not have
any control or we do not have any idea
about where this particular mail server
is and how their infrastructure consists
stop. We can assume that this external
API call usually takes somewhere around
200 to 300 millconds. Now our own
processing was around 100. Then we on
top of that added another 300 millconds
for this external API call. And after we
got the response from this external
email provider that okay this email
request has been processed then we send
a response back to the user. So the user
enters the email, clicks on the enter
button, then they see the loader for 400
milliseconds, then they see a tick mark
or a toast message. Okay, this you have
successfully invited this user and we
refresh the invited users list in the
and they can see that this user has not
accepted the invite and it's in a
pending state all that but this whole
interaction took 400 millconds but if
you think about it after doing our own
processing after adding this particular
entry in our database which was around
100 millconds what we can do instead of
making the API call making the HTTP call
to our email provider to send the email
after doing our own processing we can
send a response responds back. It's a
200 response and the user will see a
tick mark that okay this user has been
successfully invited and they will see
in their UI that okay this is in pending
state all that but now this whole user
interaction has come down from 400
millconds to 100 millconds which is a
very snappy experience even though 400
is itself not that slow but you can
assume there are other API calls maybe
the email provider is down whatever
reason is that but our goal was to
reduce the perceived latency of the user
the user who is interacting with our
system and that has come down
significantly on a server level. How we
handle it before we send a successful
response back. Usually how we implement
asynchronous processing is we take that
request of sending the email. So we call
that is some kind of task or some kind
of job. So if you have watched the
background job processing video then you
would understand what I'm talking about
since and obviously that video came
before this. So I'm assuming that you
already have the knowledge about message
cues and background job cues. So
typically we take the task of sending
the email or the job of sending the
email and we push it into queue. Now
this Q can be something like radius Q or
Rabbit MQ these are the most popular
options also other ones like Kafka event
based processing etc etc lot of options
but usually Reddis Q or Rabbit MQ based
Q library will do the job. So our server
as a producer we call it because it is
producing the task or it is producing
the job any kind of job. Now it pushes
task into a queue. This is a radius Q or
rabbit MQ based cube and there is
another phase of this Q which is a
consumer. Consumers or we also call them
workers. Now there is a distinction
here. this consumer or this worker. It
can either be in the same code that is
running your server which means it just
spins up a new worker based on the same
code or it can be a different code base
itself so that when you have a lot of
traffic you can also horizontally scale
your workers. That is another
infrastructure choice usually people
make when they're scaling their infra.
So this workers these consumer they pick
this task out of the queue when they
detect one and they perform the job or
they perform the task whatever handle
logic that we have we take the email we
make the API call to send grid resend
whatever email provider that we have and
that's done but for our users they do
not need to know all that because
sending an email or inviting a user into
the platform this is not a kind of
operation that the user needs to see the
result of instantly because anyway the
user will get an email they will
eventually come to the platform and
they'll accept the invite or reject the
invite. So this is not a synchronous
behavior-based operation or synchronous
computing synchronous behavior based
operation. So this is a very good
example and it is one of the most famous
examples of when we opt for asynchronous
processing in our backends sending
emails sending notifications also users
don't expect the moment they perform
some task in the next millisecond that
notification should be there. They don't
expect that. That is a standard user
experience. Same way another good
example is video processing. So let's
say you have a video processing
platform. Let's talk about YouTube. So
when you upload a video to YouTube, so
YouTube usually has this kind of
interaction where you pick the file and
you click upload and the upload starts.
And while that upload is happening, you
have to keep that tab open for obvious
reasons because it is reading bytes from
your local file system and it is
uploading YouTube servers. But after the
upload is finished, after the upload is
finished, you don't have to keep the tab
open. You can close the tab or whatever.
In the background, what YouTube does
after the upload is done, it pushes a
number of tasks into the queue. Whatever
Q logic they have, the most likely a
very robust Qbased logic. But typically
imagining after the upload job is
complete, it pushes a number of tasks.
The tasks like generate thumbnails and
encode the video into HD or generate
subtitles. All these tasks maybe
parallelly, maybe in sequence, whatever
logic that they have. But the point is
all these tasks are done asynchronously.
You as a user do not have to wait or you
do not expect to see all this in a
particular time frame. Sometimes all
these tasks happen let's say in 10
minutes. Sometime it might take 20
minutes depending on the server load of
YouTube etc. But the point is all these
are asynchronous processes that we as
users expect that these will take time.
So there is a category of tasks or there
is a category of operations that are out
there where you can safely offload them
to an asynchronous process. um video
uploads and image uploads, image
resizing and we already talked about
sending emails. Another thing that you
might have noticed is in some SAS
platforms there is an option to delete
account. Delete account and what does it
mean by delete account? you are using a
particular SAS for let's say 1 month or
2 months or 3 months and after 3 months
that you decided that for some reason
for some fault on their side or maybe
you do not need it anymore for some
reason you want to delete your account
and never come back or maybe you want to
come back after a year with a different
account but the point is you want to
delete your account and deleting account
usually means that deleting all your
data in that platform which means that
let's say it is a to-do based
application so if If you delete your
account, it means that deleting all your
to-dos obviously the first thing. Then
all your categories of to-dos. Then your
profile, whatever profile information
that you have used, your profile
picture, your bio etc. all your calendar
schedules. Basically, we have a lot of
database tables and in a lot of tables
we have data related to a particular
user. So imagine you are the backend
engineer of this application, this to-do
based application and a user clicks on
delete account. So what do you do in a
very naive approach? The browser makes
the request of delete account. It's a
delete HTTP API call. And what you do
you run a number of database queries in
transaction because either you want to
delete all of them or you don't want to
delete in it will be classified as a
database transaction. So first what you
do you delete all the categories of the
user that they have created. Then you
delete all the calendar schedules. Then
you delete the all the to-dos of the
user. Then you delete the user's profile
data. And at last you delete the entry
from the users table which comes last
because all these have foreign keys
associated with this table. And finally
after running delete queries in let's
say seven or eight database tables you
send a response back something like 200
and the user is logged out from the
browser. But assume that this is a big
platform or the user has let's say a
million tasks created because they've
been using for last 10 years and they
have a million tasks created and same
for other tables also. Each table has a
million rows that you have to delete. So
obviously running a delete operation
finding out all the data of the user
then deleting them takes time. So each
database table deletion takes somewhere
around 5 milliseconds let's say. So if
you deleted data from eight tables, it
took around 4 seconds and adding some
business logic related processing and
the request latency etc. The total
roundtrip time of this request response
life cycle was around 8 seconds. So the
user after clicking on delete account
they saw the spinner for 8 seconds. So 8
seconds is obviously a very bad user
experience no matter what the operation
is unless you have clearly specified in
the dialogue that please do not close
the tab or do not please wait for at
least 10 seconds or 20 seconds which
again is not something that you can
expect from your users. So in that case
also instead of doing everything
synchronously the user makes a request
to delete their account your server does
some very basic processing that checks
whether this user exists or not they're
authenticated or not which takes
somewhere around 50 to 80 millconds and
after that the server immediately sends
a response back saying that your account
is deleted and the browser sees the
successful response and logs the user
out. Okay. Now the user only had to see
the spinner for let's say for a moment
only 100 millconds and they've been
logged out. But in the background what
you do after doing all your sanity
checks checking the user exists or not
or whatever you again push a task is
called delete user with the ID of the
user or whatever into the queue and
later on the consumer can pick up the
task and that can in turn run all these
database queries one by one and it does
not matter whether it takes 5 seconds or
10 second or 30 seconds because your
user is not waiting for that response
and it all is happening in the
background after the user has been send
a response. So this is typically what we
mean by asynchronous processing. One of
the very very easy solutions when you
are trying to scale your application or
when you're trying to reduce the latency
of application a very easy solution you
just create a radius instance mostly a
managed radius something like radius
instance or opt stash which is a very
good radius instance or we have these
libraries if you're using a nodejs bull
mq bull mq is a very famous background
job based library and it uses radius
behind the scenes radius pops up But it
manages a lot of things like error
handling, rate limiting and all the
things that you expect from a production
grade robust queue. So you can use
something like this and you can easily
implement a background job a Q- based
solution for your asynchronous based
task. Of course the first thing is to
identify which kind of task which task
exactly can you offload to your queue.
So as I already said things like sending
emails, sending notifications, deleting
user data, video uploads, image uploads,
all these tasks where the user does not
expect to see the response immediately,
you can offload to a queue and that in
turn significantly improves your
perceived latency. A very easy solution
and a very recommended solution while
you are trying to increase the
performance of your application and
reduce the latency. Now moving on to
another important question which is
micro services. Very fancy term and a
very trendy term. If you are a backend
engineer even a front-end engineer also
at some point you will keep hearing this
term called microservices because
apparently every company these days goes
for this microser architecture. Whenever
you ask around about how to scale your
application, how to scale your back end
application, someone is going to suggest
you eventually that you should divide
your application into multiple
independent services or also called as
microservices. That is the only way to
scale your application or maybe you'll
join a company one day which already
uses this micros service-based
architecture. So understanding this what
are microservices and when do we use
them is important. Of course, dealing
with microservices or implementing
microservices is a very different topic
in itself and it involves a lot of
technologies and a lot of methodologies.
We'll not get into that but we'll talk
briefly about microservices and what
role they play in scaling your wagon. So
let's start with what we currently have
right now which we call is monoliths.
What is a monolith? A monolith is an
application and whenever I say
application I mean a backend application
because that's what we are talking about
currently. So a monolith is an
application which is considered as a
single deployable unit. So all
functionality does not matter whether it
is authentication functionality or your
order processing, your notifications,
your payments, your web hooks, all these
functionalities are just different
different files in your codebase and all
of them live in the same codebase. They
interact with each other and they
function together. And you can take all
of this every time you make a change.
You take all of this and you deploy your
an application which serves your users,
right? One single deployable unit which
runs as a single process or if you're
horizontally scaling multiple process
but one process consists of all these
things together. They are just different
modules in a same service or in a same
application. And monoliths are pretty
intuitive and pretty easy to manage
because they are very simple to develop.
They are very simple to test and they
are very simple to deploy. All your code
lives in one place in your one codebase,
one GitHub repository. Whenever you
refactor, you make a change in one
module and you go to the other module,
make the change and you take all that
and you deploy that. So refactoring is
also very straightforward. Testing is
also very straightforward because
everything runs in one process and
deployment is obviously simple from the
start. Now the question is why would you
consider anything else? Why would you
even think about microservices? You can
just take a monolith and you can
horizontally scale it whenever you want
to scale your application. You always
have the option of horizontally scaling
your monolith application. So why do you
need microser? Now microservices
primarily they are not necessarily to
scale your performance of your
application but microservices are more
about scaling your team. It's more about
scaling your human interaction. It's not
really about scaling your machine's
performance. It's about scaling your
team's performance. The humans behind
the machine because monoliths have a
couple of problems. If you are working
in a large team that is that is the
number one prerequisite of having a
micros service based architecture if you
don't have a large team and when I say
large it can be subjective but we are
talking about more than 100 or 200
developers working on the same
application that's the point when you
start considering a micros service
architecture so what are the problems of
monoliths one obvious one is the
deployment dependency and what do you
mean by that let's say we have different
different modules in our application. We
have our payment module. We have our
order processing. It's an e-commerce
based application that you can imagine.
We have our notification based module
and the people the engineers who are
working on the payments module they
implemented some critical change or some
important user experience which change
and they want to deploy that so that
users can start using that. But while
they do that there are some changes from
our notification team in our main
branch. Typically the branch that we
deploy in production they have some
change in the main branch which is not
ready yet it's not broken but it is not
ready for sending to our users. Now of
course you can say that there are
solutions like feature flags. There are
solution like planning your life cycle
in a way that you only keep the ready to
deploy things in your main branch. But
in a very abstract way in a very
oversimplified way you can imagine like
you have some changes in one module but
since it is a monolith application and
since you have to deploy everything as a
single module sometimes you will face
difficulties. Again as I said these
problems you cannot relate unless you
work in a very large team and the
communication between different teams
it's not as close because typically when
we work in a startups 10 15 or 30
developers pretty much everybody knows
what everybody is working on. The team
works in a very closely coupled way. So
we are able to plan our things our git
life cycle our feature flag and
everything in a way that this particular
problem does not happen. If something is
on main branch then we can go ahead and
deploy it. But if it is a very lasting
500 developers or thousand developers
you will start seeing this problem that
when rapid development is happening in
one module and another module is not
ready yet this problem will start
happening. So that is one the
organization based problem. The second
one is scaling which is an obvious one.
Taking the same three modules for
example our notification module let's
say it is not as resourceheavy we just
make some database queries and we just
insert some database queries because it
is inapp notification and maybe some
websocket based operation but our order
processing logic or our payment based
logic it requires a lot of resources a
lot of CPU resources a lot of memory
resources and basically harder resources
if we get a lot of user traffic or if we
are expecting a lot user traffic. If you
want to be ready to the point that we
cannot afford any kind of payment
related failures or order related
failures, then we have to scale our back
end applications vertical scaling or
horizontal scaling. But the problem is
when we scale our application, we scale
the whole thing. We cannot say that okay
since notification does not use as much
amount of resource, we do not want to
scale notification. We only want to
scale payments. We cannot do that. We
cannot scale independent modules. So
that is another use case of
microservices. You can since you have
already divided services into different
maybe code bases or maybe not but
different deployable units and because
of that you can scale different services
depending on your expected user traffic
or your current user traffic independent
of other modules. Third thing is text
stack. So let's say you have a blog
platform something like medium. You are
an engineer of an platform like medium
or hash node or dev all these famous
blogging platforms and in your back end
there are some parts where you have to
deal with markdowns since is a blogging
based application and you have to deal
with markdown based cleaning or maybe
some kind of website parsing and all
these different stuff and for this you
either have to go with a NodeJS app or a
Python app because in NodeJS and Python
ecosystems there is a choice of
thousands and millions of libraries for
pretty much all the use cases. So you
found out that for a particular
operation let's say a markdown based
parsing or markdown based rendering
application there is a very famous
library. So this part of your module
which deals with content or especially a
markdown content it absolutely needs a
NodeJS based environment because it has
to use a particular npm package but in a
different part in a different part of
your same back end let's say you are
taking the images that the user uploads
and you do some kind of image
manipulation or image resizing or any
kind of image related operation and you
find that using a programming language
like Go or Rust makes this whole image
manipulation based operation very fast.
Since these programming languages are
very efficient at CPUbound tasks and if
you use something like Python or NodeJS
for this, the latency becomes something
like 500 millconds. And when you use Go
or Rust, it becomes 50 mconds. Though
obviously the performance benefits are
huge. But since for one module you need
in the NodeJS ecosystem since you have
to use an npm package or a Python
library and another module where it is
CPU bound you need pure raw performance
of a systems based programming language.
Now you face another dilemma that since
all your modules are a single deployable
unit, you cannot use different
programming languages. And if you have
microservices, you can just divide this
into a different service which uses
NodeJS and this into a different service
which use Rust and you deploy this
separately and you deploy this
separately. That is another advantage.
So these are a couple of very obvious
advantages of using microser not just
for pure machine performance but mostly
for organizational performance. Now the
question is if microservices have all
these performance organizational wins
then why don't we use microservices as a
default architecture and as we already
know every solution comes with its
trade-offs. So microser also come with a
lot of trade-offs, a lot of
disadvantages also, a lot of
complexities also. The first one is
network since you have divided your
application into different different
services. Previously it was just depend
different modules all of the code work
together and was deployed as a single
process and now you have divided into
different service and they have physical
distance between them. So previously it
was just a pure function call. Now it
has become a network call. Whether it is
a gRPC based network call or an HTTP
network call, it can be any of them. But
the truth is it is still a network call.
So the latency will start showing up
depending on how you're organizing your
services. And latency is not just the
only problem. The moment we talk about
networks, there is obviously the
question of failures. An HTTP call might
fail, right? So you have to start
worrying about how to handle your
failures, how to retry etc. How to
configure timeouts. So dealing with
network is a huge complexity that comes
the moment you go for a micros
service-based architecture. Second is
microservices are primarily a
distributed systemsbased architecture
and when you're trying to understand a
request let's say you are trying to
debug a particular request and you find
out at the entry point let's say the
request went through your load balancer
then it went through your routing layer
then it went to your order service then
it went to your payment service then it
went to your notification service etc
etc. So if you want to debug a
particular request, you have to check
logs of four different services
primarily four different services at the
same time to understand a simple
request. So debugging becomes a little
complex. You have to opt for distributed
tracing based tools that we have and you
also have to architect your applications
in a way that they make it easy for
debugging a single request across
different different services. Then third
is data consistency. When we are talking
about very complex micros service based
architecture, each service eventually
holds an instance of its own database
and as we have already talked about when
we are talking about scaling your
database or different different
databases number one concern is
consistency. How do we make sure that
change in one database even though we
have features like replication etc etc
but still there is some amount of
replication lag that comes the moment we
talk about different different database
instances. So that becomes another
problem you have to start worrying about
replication lag or data consistency
across different different databases and
there are other disadvantages of
microservices that you can read more
about. But the question is when do you
decide or how do you decide that
microservices are a very good solution
for you? As I have already said large
teams are one of the mandatory
requirements before you even consider a
micros service-based architecture
because large teams intuitively have
very clear boundaries and microser
architecture itself has very clear
boundaries so that human organization
and this technical organization aligns
very well. The second obvious criteria
is different scaling needs. As we talked
about, if one service needs to scale
independently, then something like
microservices makes a lot of sense. Then
technology, if you need to use different
different technology for different
different parts of your back end, then
also microser make a lot of sense. But
all these complexities that we talked
about in microservices, they outweigh
the advantages. So going for a micros
service-based architecture is a very big
decision. And unless you have clear
answers for all these questions, whether
you have a large team or not, whether
you have very specific technology
requirements across your different
different parts of your back end and
your deployment velocity, etc., etc.,
going for a microser based architecture
is typically not worth it. And the last
thing that I want to talk about in the
context of performance and scaling is
serverless which has in modern times
become the go-to way of scaling any kind
of applications especially backend
applications with the advent of
platforms like Versel, Netleifi,
Cloudflare which have popularized
serverless computing to a large extent.
I have created a different playlist
where I talk solely about serverless
computing, their origin, how it all
started and how platforms like Versel
work, how serverless databases work and
everything related to serverless. If you
are more curious about how serverless
computing works, you can of course give
that playlist a watch. But here we are
going to talk about the intuition of
serverless since we are already talking
about scaling and serless is such an
important part of that process. Now
before we talk about serverless
computing we need to understand what
came before that. So when you run your
application a backend application it
runs on a server which means some kind
of VM inless EC2 or whatever cloud
you're using it runs on a server which
has an operating system like Ubuntu some
kind of Unix distribution. So
traditionally what you do you take a VM
from a cloud provider which comes with
an operating system like Ubuntu. You
configure or you provision your server
there. You install whatever software
that you need like NX or Docker or
containerizing your application.
Whatever stack that you have for
deploying your application. You install
all those applications. You configure it
so that it can fetch your code or it can
build your core or it can run your code
etc etc. configure that particular
server with your application and you
keep managing that server how it works
whether the configuration breaks or not
whether the DNS is working or not and
all of that you are responsible for
managing your server throughout the
lifetime as long as you are using that
server now this whole process this whole
model of deploying our application or
provisioning our server has been working
for decades now you know exactly what
you have with a particular VM or a
particular machine with two cores of CPU
or four cores of CPU or 16 GB of RAM, 32
GB of RAM or 4 GB of RAM and you have 30
GB of SSD capacity or hard drive
whatever you want to call and what
network capacity that you have something
like 1 TB in a month or whatever that
your cloud provider is providing you and
your application runs on this particular
machine with this limit with 4 GB of
RAM, two core CPU, 30 GB of hard drive
space and one terab terabyte of
bandwidth per month. You know exactly
what you're getting, the exact machine
that you are getting and your
application starts serving starts
processing requests as they arrive. Now
the challenge that arises with this kind
of setup or this kind of model is first
one is capacity planning. What do you
mean by capacity planning? It means that
you need to decide beforehand before you
even start serving your users. You need
to decide how many servers if you are
going for horizontal scaling how many
servers that you need and for each
server what should be the capacity of
the machine how much RAM it should have
how much CPU cores it should have and
how much hard drive capacity that it
should have all of this you have to
decide beforehand which means that you
have to predict your user traffic you
have to predict your users's behavior
before you even deploy your application
why because if you provision too little
let's say you only provision for 4GB of
RAM for your server and a huge traffic
spike happens because of some kind of
online campaign or some kind of blog and
your server is not able to process that
many requests per second and it starts
crashing. So either that or your server
becomes very unresponsive. Every request
takes 3 to 4 seconds to send a response
back. So your users either they will
start experiencing slowness or they will
start experiencing a lot of errors, a
lot of error toast messages in their
front end and because of that they will
start quitting your application. If they
are new users then you lost a chance for
them to become your paid users. But if
they are already paid users they might
be motivated to quit your platform and
start looking for alternatives. The
point is you start experiencing losses
either financial losses or loss in terms
of reputation because you could not
predict your user traffic or you could
not plan what kind of traffic that you
might receive and you could not plan the
capacity of your server according to
that. And the other side of that is if
you provisioned too much. Let's say you
did not want to risk all of this and
instead of going for 4 GB RAM, you went
for 32GB of RAM and the traffic spike
happened and your server got request and
it was able to send all the responses
back. But since you overprovisioned
which means you configured a capacity
which is much more than what you needed.
You only needed 8 GB of RAM which would
have done the job perfectly depending on
the user traffic. But since you went
ahead and configured 32GB of RAM for
your server instance, you had to pay for
this machine for as long as it was
running. Let's say you ran it for 1
week. then it cost you around, let's
say, $5,000 for running at 32GB RAM of
capacity. Even though you only used 20%
of the capacity, if you had configured 8
GB of RAM, then it would have only cost
you around $500. But now it cost you
$5,000. Why? Because you could not
predict your user traffic. Again, it
does not matter whether you
underprovision or you overprovision. In
both cases, you suffer some amount of
loss because predicting is obviously
impossible of your user behavior. There
is an obvious solution to this and it
has been around for a long time which is
autoscaling. Autoscaling. What is
autoscaling? Autoscaling basically means
depending on your CPU usage. Let's say
you initially provisioned only two
servers of 4 GB RAM each, a lot of users
started coming. So these two servers
resource usage will start going up and
an autoscaling config will detect that
these two servers have already reached
70% of their memory usage. So what it
will do it will spin up a new instance.
Now all these requests will start
getting distributed across three servers
and the memory usage of each server will
come down to 40%. So autoscaling is
definitely a solution for our problem of
underprovisioning or overprovisioning
but it again comes with a couple of
drawbacks or a couple of trade-offs.
Number one is time. When we say your
autoscaling config or your autoscaling
infrastructure, it spins up a new server
instance. What it means is it starts
provisioning a new server. And what that
includes first booting a new operating
system. You are most likely using some
kind of Linux distribution something
like Ubuntu. The first thing that
happens when we say we are spinning up a
new instance through our autoscaling
config is booting up the operating
system Ubuntu operating system. Second,
configuring your application which means
building your code or fetching your code
and starting your application in a
process then exposing that process to
the internal network to our load
balancer etc etc whatever it takes to
configure our application and all of
this depending on what operating system
that you use, what programming language
that you use, the build time and
everything. All of this can take
somewhere from a few seconds to a few
minutes. So if a lot of users start
sending you request in a very small
window, let's say in 3 to 4 seconds,
your autoscaling infrastructure might
not have enough time to scale because of
this constraint of how much time it
takes to boot up a new server instance.
Second, scaling has its limits. Whenever
you are configuring your autoscaling
infrastructure, there are two fields
that you have to set. One is the minimum
instance and the second is the maximum
instance. If you set maximum too low as
we talking about earlier now you're back
to your underprovisioning problem which
means after a certain amount of instance
let's say after 10 instances you set in
your autoscaling infra that you cannot
scale beyond 10 instances. So now you're
capped at this and if you get even more
amount of user traffic then they'll
start experiencing the same
unresponsiveness and errors. If you set
the maximum too high, let's say you set
the maximum as thousand in the sense
that you don't care how many instances
you spin up, but you have to cater to
all of your users traffic. If this
happens and some kind of attack happens
or maybe it is a genuine user traffic,
let's say some Black Friday sale is
happening. Now your user traffic because
of your user traffic, your instances
actually went up till let's say 500 or
600 and because of that you incurred a
charge of something like $100,000 in one
day. and now you're beyond your budget.
That is a completely different problem.
Third is a very serious problem which is
the reactiveness of autoscaling which
means that the way autoscaling works is
let's say you have two instances which
we have already talked about and the
memory of age is 4 GB RAM. The
autoscaling infrastructure will only
start spinning up new containers or
spinning up new instances of your server
when it starts seeing that your memory
has crossed 70% threshold. Now by the
time it starts a new server instance you
are already overloaded because it is
reactive. It is not proactive. It cannot
predict the user traffic beforehand. It
can only spin up new instances when it
knows that you are under load. And if
that window of time is too less then you
cannot say that you will be able to
scale in time. You might still
experience crashes or errors. But even
though we have all these limitations of
autoscaling, autoscaling is still one of
the most standard practice for scaling
our applications. But the other problem
which is the the always on cost even
with autoscaling you have a minimum. Now
if we are talking in the context of
horizontal scaling maybe you have two
instance minimum but even if you talk
about vertical scaling or you think
about in the context of a single machine
you still have a minimum which is that
machine's configuration let's say this
machine has 4 GB of RAM two cores of CPU
30 GB of hard disk this is your minimum
it does not matter whether you have a
500 requests per second or you have zero
requests per second you are constantly
paying for this server for this
particular configuration which is your
machine's minimum capacity. So if your
application is something which receives
constant and steady amount of requests a
very predictable flow of request then
this model definitely makes sense. The
traditional serverful model the server
which is always online even if there is
one request it can still cater to it and
it can still send a response back for
that kind of setup. This model makes a
lot of sense which is typically most of
our SAS applications but because of some
requirements some kind of setups where
this does not make any sense which does
not have very predictable amount of user
request people have come up with a new
model which is called serverless. Now
simply speaking what serverless means is
you do not worry about servers at all.
It's not like serverless does not
include servers. They definitely include
server otherwise there is no amount of
processing that can happen. We still
need a machine. We still need a VM. We
still need some kind of operating system
and we still need to configure our
application in that operating system so
that it can start responding to
requests. But the difference between
serverless and a traditional
architecture is you do not have to worry
about the machines itself. You do not
have to worry about the operating
system. You do not have to worry about
whether your server has 4 GB of RAM, 8
GB of RAM, nothing. And you do not have
to worry about configuring your server
to work with your operating system or to
work with your server. The only thing
that you manage, the only thing that you
provide is you provide your code or in
serverless terminology, we call it
functions. Particular functions which
will be triggered based on particular
events. These are the two core
functionalities. These are the only two
things you have to worry about. These
are the only two things you have to
manage. The way the computing model
differs from traditional computing is
let's say you get a request and there is
some kind of front here. You of course
do not go to your function execution
layer, your serverless layer directly.
Usually we have what we call as an API
gateway here which means that it takes
HTTP calls at this point and depending
on what route that we are trying to
access it spins up a particular
function. So it maps routes to the
functions address since we as developers
we only worry about functions and the
events. So the events are these routes
and the functions are the code that we
write. So API gateway works as a
middleman which takes a particular user
request. If we are talking about
traditional backend based request
response cycle comparing with serverless
this is how it would work. Then APA
gateway lives here it takes an HTTP
request depending on the route it spins
up a new function. So what does it mean
to spin up a new function or spin up a
new uh serverless function is
traditionally what we were saying we
have a server it has some amount of
capacity let's say 4 GB of RAM two core
processor 30 GB hard disk etc and it is
always ready to cater to any amount of
requests whether it is zero request
whether it is 500 request it's always
there always present always listening
for requests and we are paying for this
how serverless works we do not worry
about the machine's capacity or the
machine at all we just Okay, if there is
a request for this route, we want to run
this particular piece of code. That's
all we say. Now the provider, our
serverless provider, whether it is
lambda or cloudflare workers etc etc.
Now they handle this machine handling
part. So when a new request arrives,
let's say it is the first time you
deploy your server, no machine is
provisioned for you. You just push your
code and it's just there. But the first
time a new request arrives or a new
event happens which needs the code
running the serverless infrastructure
your serverless provider it takes your
code whatever that you have provided it
spins up a new instance this machine now
we don't know what machine is this or
how much capacity it has or whatever any
information about the machine just that
our code is going to run in some machine
and it is going to send a response back
and this happens only after we get a
request and After we send the response
back either depending on your
configuration of your serverless
infrastructure provider it lives for a
few seconds let's say 3 5 seconds or 30
seconds or it goes to a pool of
connections so that when the next
request comes instead of spinning a new
machine an existing machine can cater to
that request that is the difference in
the computing model. The second
difference is the pricing model. In our
traditional servers, we always pay for
our servers 24/7 cost. As long as our
server is running, we pay for that. But
in serverless based setup, we only pay
for this interaction. The request, the
moment our request comes here and our
serverless instance spins up, whatever
processing that we do here, we only pay
for that amount of time, the CPU time,
the memory time, whatever it is. The
moment we send the response back, we are
done with this. So our monthly cost is
only going to be a sum of all these
interactions, all the milliseconds that
the CPU was actually executing our code.
So which in turn saves a lot of money
because we're not paying for 24/7. Now
the question is where is the catch?
Since we already know no solution comes
without its own set of trade-offs. So
the number one problem the number one
issue that we face when it comes to
serverless computing is what we call as
cold start times. Since the way
serverless works is we do not have any
pre-assigned machine. We do not have any
machine which is ready to take any
request. We only spin up a new machine a
physical server. Does not matter the
capacity of the server but we only spin
up a new physical instance of a server
after getting the first request. And
that instance only lives for a few more
seconds until we give it back or we
close the instance forever. Because of
this nature, this time which it takes to
spin up a new instance, this is what we
call as a cold start time. This has
always been the number one problem of
using serverless technologies. Now there
has been a lot of solutions people are
still inventing to get around the cold
start problem of serverless. Some of the
famous ones are keeping a few instances
always ready through some kind of
automated pings. Right? You automate a
couple of requests from your own
infrastructure so that every few seconds
you send a request so that an instance
comes up to cater to that request so
that when an actual user request comes
there is an instance always ready to
serve to that user's request. So this
hack exists but you cannot go overboard
with it. Otherwise you'll end up with
always having a few instances of your
servers ready and you again start paying
for them 24/7 which completely defeats
the problem of serless again. So that is
one solution that we have come up with.
Second is another one which is the most
efficient one that you can say which is
coming up with runtimes with minimum
cold start. Some of the largest reasons
of big cold start timing is two reasons.
One is booting up a new operating system
or a new VM which comes with an
operating system. Second is the language
runtime. Whether it is it can be a Java
application or a rust application or go
application or a NodeJS application or a
Python application whatever your
language is. These are the two primary
calls of cold start time. one if it is a
traditional VM something like hypervisor
or VM etc etc then that takes a long
time to boot up a new operating system
to prevent the OS related the VM related
cold start timing has come up with this
new container technology new VM
technology a new VM technology which
works which is called as KVM technology
called firecrackers which is what they
use for their lambdas and this has
become the indust industry standard for
any kind of serverless based
architecture. The second one, the second
major one you can say is Cloudflare
workers. They are again one of the
largest providers of serverless
computing. They use V8 isolates. Now V8
is a JavaScript runtime which you can
read more about. But V8 isolates, they
provide an isolation level, a VM like
functionality where your code can run
which is extremely fast. They claim that
it's something like 0 to 1 millconds to
boot up a new V8 isolate. So these kinds
of technology that we keep innovating
they help with the cold start timing of
operating system related. The second is
language. A language like JavaScript or
Python which is an interpreted language
which means it does not have any kind of
compilation step. You just provide the
code and the code starts running line by
line. there is no pre-ompiled phase and
because of that these languages are much
faster in a serverless environment
compared to a language like Java which
has its own compilation JVM and all that
and same for other system languages
which has a compilation phase. So that
is another big factor and that is why
Cloudflare workers the one of the
largest providers of serverless
computing they use V8 isolates which
prevents the OS booting problem and they
use JavaScript. So combined with these
two they have extremely low cold start
time somewhere around 5 millconds you
can say but again the cold start timings
will always be there. We can never beat
the traditional serverful compute when
it comes to cold start because
traditional servers are always online
always online to cater to our requests.
But every time we talk about serverless
computing the cold start problem will
always be there because of the nature of
how serverless computing works. Now
second problem first was the cold start
timing. Second was limits. Most of these
serverless providers levelless lambda
they have some amount of limit. For
example the list lambda functions they
can run for at least like 15 minutes. So
if you have a long running HTTP call
something which takes a long amount of
time like 30 minutes then this will fail
halfway right. So most of the serverless
computing environments they have certain
amount of limits on how long they can
keep the request alive. Third is
statelessness. Now this is a big problem
which we discuss in depth in the
serverless based video. But in short
most of our setup in a traditional
server it is based on the premise that
our server is stateful which means that
to interact with the database we
establish TCP connections which is a
active connection that we hold with our
database. Same way if we have some kind
of websocket based connection that we
established with our browsers.
Similarly, we have a lot of stateful
behaviors associated with our
traditional servers. But the moment we
are talking about serverless which
because of their execution limits, they
can only be alive for a few seconds or
they cannot hold any data inside the
operating system because every few
seconds we are replacing the machines.
We are running the same code but the
machines in which the code is running
they keep getting replaced depending on
the user traffic and because of all
these behaviors our architecture when it
comes to serless is primarily stateless.
So all these behaviors of statefulness
the TCP connections the websocket
connections all of these have to be
reimagined on how they work the moment
you go and start using a serverless
based architecture in your back end. So
with all this when should you start
using or when should you start migrating
to a serverless architecture. Now it is
easy to say when should you not use a
serverless architecture which is latency
sensitive applications. Latency plays a
huge role something like any kind of
userfacing sensitive application like
banking application or payment based
applications where latency you cannot
afford any amount of latency. Then
serverless does not make a lot of sense.
Then comes the long running procedures.
If you have HTTP calls or websocket
connections on somewhere then serverless
does not make a lot of sense or
applications which require a lot of
database connections then also you'll
have to figure out a lot of missing
components you have to opt for a
serverless database if you make your
backend serverless first. So some of the
ideal use cases of serverless that we
typically use is very specific
operations in our workflow. One famous
one is video processing or image
processing or image resizing as it is
since these are tasks or jobs in our
application which is not very regular
unless it is your application purely
does video processing it is not very
regular. So in a typical serverlessbased
architecture we can just instead of
running our heavy infrastructure heavy
infrastructure which handles the video
processing the image processing etc
instead of paying for that 24/7 we just
keep a serverless instance and depending
on when we get a request to process a
new video or process a new image we can
spin up a new serverless instance and
finish the task and return a response.
So that is a very good use case for
serless or any kind of event based
operations for example a new message
appeared in cues or any kind of file
upload that I just mentioned or
something like a database changes. So if
you are thinking in the context of event
triggering some kind of pipeline or
event triggering some kind of operation
there also serverless makes a lot of
sense. Currently the industry is
somewhat overhyped when it comes to
serverless. It is definitely a powerful
tool for very specific use cases but in
my opinion not a universal replacement
for servers but understanding where it
fits why we have come up with it how it
works and when should you use it
definitely is a very good tool in your
arsenal whenever you are thinking in the
context of scaling and performance. So
we have covered a lot of topics in both
of these videos about scaling and
performance from the fundamentals of
latency and throughput through database
optimization and caching and vertical
scaling horizontal scaling distributed
systems and infrastructure components
that come into play like API gateways
load balancers and organization
practices when it comes to microservices
etc etc. So let let me summarize it. Let
me give you a couple of thumb rules, a
couple of mental models that you can
take away from all this information.
First one is always start with a
problem. All these things, all these
techniques, all these topics that we
discussed in these videos, they are
primarily solutions. So even though we
came from a context of what problem they
solve, but still the discussions were
about solutions. So before you start
reaching for solutions, you should
understand where you stand with your
problem. Whether your system is actually
slow or not and how slow is that you
have to actually measure your system
using practices like observability,
using traces, metrices, logs and
performance testing, load etc. So
measuring is a very big part which
answers your question where exactly your
system is slow. Which component is
exactly slow in your whole system? What
exactly is your bottleneck? Unless you
know the answers to these and you know
the specific answer to this, you have to
know that if your database is the
bottleneck, then it is the bottleneck
because of the absence of this
particular index. It is the bottleneck
because of the absence of sharding.
Unless you know the specific answers all
these solutions that we talked about you
should not opt for them because when we
do that that's what we call as premature
optimization which is not something I
would advise so always measure first
measure everything then profile trace
your requests there are tools that you
can configure like Prometheus Graphana
to trace every single request to find
out where your bottlenecks are or you
can go with some paid service or some
managed tool something like New Relic
which makes measuring your system a lot
easier. And after doing all this,
understand where actually the time goes
before trying to make your system faster
because the worst thing that you can do
while solving your performance related
problems is solving the wrong problem or
fixing the wrong bottleneck because it
gives you the impression that you have
fixed your problem which in turn becomes
a much larger problem along the way. So
if you want to take something from both
of these videos, this advice, measure
every single interaction of your system
using tools like New Relic or if you
want to go to the custom solution
something like Prometheus Graphana only
after you have measured every single
component of your system only after you
know all the numbers. What is your
average latency? What is your average
amount of errors and everything once you
have all the numbers in front of you
then only go for solutions only after
that go for caching go for aggressive
indexing and whatever all the solutions
that we discuss in this video. Second
always prefer simple solutions. What do
we mean by simple solutions? One example
that we discussed just before this was
the microser architecture. Now microser
architecture is one of those things
which do have a lot of benefits but the
complexities that they come with. It is
usually not worth switching and
microservices are not what we call as a
simple solution. It can get very
complicated unless you have experience
dealing with and handling microservices.
So that is one example. Same way while
we are discussing horizontal scaling
dealing with something like Kubernetes
if you are interacting with your infra
part dealing with Kubernetes is again
what we will not consider as a simple
solution. So unless you have no choices
left and unless you know you definitely
need this particular tool then only go
for these complicated solutions
otherwise always try to stick to simple
solution because they are easy to
understand they are easy to debug and
they are easy to operate. So starting
with a large server with a large
vertical scaling based solution is
always simpler than going with like from
day one of development going with a
horizontal scaling based architecture.
Right? Same way indexing your database
queries. Implementing proper indices for
your database query is a much simpler
solution than placing a radius cache in
front all of your database queries. And
a monolith is always simpler than going
with a micros servicebased architecture
because complexity has costs. It always
has costs. Every component that you add
to a system is another component that
can fail is another component that you
have to monitor. Is another component
that you have to understand and operate.
So only accept complexity when
simplicity is genuinely insufficient.
You have no other choices. Of course,
this does not mean that you always
choose the simplest possible approach.
Sometimes complexity is necessary, but
you have to understand the fact that
complexity is a cost and it requires
enough amount of justification before
you start implementing it. Third, scale
for the problems you have. What do you
mean by this? You do not need to build
for a million users on your first day of
development. you probably will not ever
reach a million users. Most platforms do
not make it. So build for the scale that
you currently have with some headroom
for growth, keeping some amount of
buffer, reasonable buffer. And as you
grow, you will learn where your
bottlenecks are. As long as you have
properly implemented your observability,
which means your logs, metrics, and
traces. Your specific application has
its own set of specific characteristics.
So generic advice from internet from
from engineering blogs that are from big
companies Netflix or Facebook or Google
they might not apply to your specific
situation. So learning from measuring
your system is much more valuable and a
much more solid approach as compared to
taking some performance engineering blog
from a big company and start
implementing their solution for your
systems. Which brings me to the fourth
problem and measure. Now I cannot stress
this enough. Observability is one of
those components in your backend systems
that you should have from day one. So in
the first point as I said that always go
for the simplest solution. So this is
one of those cases where you have to
make an exception. Now you might think
that on your day one going for simple
logs and ignoring metrics and traces are
a good way until you reach like 50,000
users or one lakh users. But from my
experience, measuring your systems,
which means implementing proper
production grade observability from day
one always pays off. You never have to
face random errors. You never have to
face random crashes in your system. You
never have to guess where your system's
bottleneck is. Everything is in front of
your face all the time. And as your
system grows, you have enough headroom.
You get enough headsups that you can
scale. You can make changes to your
system. You can make changes to your
infra before they cause any kind of
problems because you measure every
single thing. So this is very important.
Now the last thing is mindset. Similarly
as we talked about in the security
video, security is a mindset. You have
to constantly learn about new threats.
You have to constantly learn about new
ways to secure our application. Same way
performance optimization and scaling is
an ongoing learning phase. It is a
mindset and it comes from experience.
You will build your systems and you will
watch your systems struggle and you will
optimize and see what helps and what
does not help. And over the time after a
lot of trial and errors you can say that
your system can scale. Your system has
all the performance tweaks all the
performance related changes all the
scaling needs so that it can cater to
any amount of user traffic. At least the
kind of user traffic your application
gets, not the generic number based user
traffic. And a single tutorial cannot
teach you all that. Your job as a
backend engineer is not to predict all
kinds of problems that can happen, but
to build systems that handle problems
when they do happen in a graceful manner
and to develop skills so that you can
measure these things and so that you can
diagnose these problems and you can
resolve them quickly when they do